members will vote on the candidate  proposed by EU leaders for presidents of  the European Commission German Defense  Minister Ursula Fonda Lyon  Parliament will review Romania's first  stint at the head of the six-month  rotating presidency of the Council of  the EU which ended in June and debate  the priorities of Finland which takes  over the presidency for the second half  of 2019 Parliament will decide the  number of MEP zin each into  parliamentary delegation in charge of  managing relations with Parliament's of  non-eu countries regions or  organisations following the case of the  rescue ship see watch stranded for days  off the coast of Sicily with dozens of  migrants on board members will discuss  humanitarian aid and security in the  Mediterranean  [Music]